The entire kind of arc of human history
has really been defined
by how we harness and capture energy.
You know, initially starting
with us leveraging things like fire
and then later coal and
petroleum fuel sources
for our energy needs.
And really the great opportunity
going forward is this idea
that we can capture
renewable energy sources,
store that energy in batteries
and then use that to power our lives.
Advances in battery design
over the past few decades
have made modern technology
possible, but it's not enough.
We need better, cheaper,
more energy dense batteries
if we're going to make
electric cars ubiquitous
and save the planet.
Now companies are on the
verge of battery breakthroughs
that could change the world.
The battery industry
has been kind of stuck
making batteries one way
for like 50 years and we think
it's just time for that to change.
A battery looks like a black
box quite literally sometimes
but inside it is a very
complex mixture of chemicals.
There are four components.
There are two electrodes,
cathode and anode,
there's a separator
and then there's a liquid
electrolyte typically.
And the electrolyte's job is to be able
to shuttle irons between
the two electrodes.
And that's what charges the battery
and that's what allows the
battery to be then discharged
and produce power.
Among the everyday technologies,
batteries are perhaps one of the oldest
because batteries were invented even
before electricity was invented
which is to say there was no
way to generate electricity
until somebody made a battery
and that was back in 1799
by an Italian scientist named Volta.
And what he created was
actually called a voltaic pile.
It wasn't even called a battery back then.
And it was called a pile because
it was literally a pile of
two different types of metal
in this case, copper and zinc separated
by typically a piece of cardboard
that was dipped in vinegar
To get a feel for how a battery works,
we decided to build our own.
I got a copper sheet, I
got a couple zinc sheets.
I cut them into one by one squares
and I also got a coffee filter
that I cut into one inch squares too.
Right, just to start off,
keep a simple aluminum foil
at the bottom.
Okay.
So that you're able to test
whether the battery is working or not.
On top of you put a copper sheet.
And so now you have to
dip the coffee filter
into a solution of salt and water.
Okay.
Then you put your coffee filter.
Done.
Then you place
the zinc sheet on top.
You also have a voltmeter which basically
will be able to measure the voltage
that this battery will have.
Okay so we're getting 0.74 volts.
Yeah, that sounds about right.
Yeah.
Now you can connect a
copper cable on either ends
and you could solider that on
then you can connect
it to say an LED light
and that should light up.
The more cells you pile
on the higher the voltage.
We piled on 10 layers of zinc and copper
to see if we could power up an LED light.
So let's test it with an LED light.
Okay, it's the moment of truth here.
There we go.
And that's electricity.
Cool.
Batteries have come a long
way since the voltaic pile
but they're still made up of
the full basic components,
anode, cathode, separator,
and electrolyte.
The current state of the
art lithium-ion battery
is small, light and relatively powerful
making everything from mobile devices
to electric cars possible.
But in order to make
de-carbonization a reality,
batteries need to get much better.
We are quite far away from the limits
of what a battery can do.
Among the different things about batteries
that still need to be improved
is not just the amount
of energy they can store
but they also have to do it safely.
Batteries also need to
be charged more quickly
and finally batteries
still aren't cheap enough.
They probably need to be half the price
to be able to compete with
the gasoline powered engine.
To accomplish all that,
a number of companies
are going inside the black box
and tinkering with those
four basic components,
hoping to jumpstart the next
generation of batteries.
Batteries have a long history
of pretty slow improvement
on the order of four to 5% a year.
Think we're one of the few companies
that are actually trying
to do something pretty
revolutionary in this space.
Harold Rust company, Enovix,
based just South of San Francisco
is making one seemingly small tweak
to the lithium-ion battery.
Replacing the anode typically
made of carbon with silicon.
So the major advantage of silicon
is it has three times the
energy density of carbon
which it replaces so that
allows you to pack more stuff
in your battery and
drive up energy density.
But silicon well, it's a great anode
suffers from a bunch of problems
and the biggest of which is
the fact that it expands 300%.
Easy way to think about it is
when you're charging a cell
the silicon tends to expand
and when you discharge it,
it compresses or contracts.
That's a potentially
battery busting problem.
But in Enovix claims to
have found a solution.
A complex method of arranging
the batteries components
that keeps the silicon under pressure.
This 3D architecture allows
us to constrain that expansion
in a very uniform way within the cell
that allows us to maintain
a very long cycle life.
It allows us to basically
manage that swelling
without any macroscopic
growth of the battery.
A silicon anode battery could
store about 50% more energy
than what's currently on the market.
Which could mean we'll be
seeing lighter electronics
with longer battery
life in the near future.
We've been actively sampling batteries
over the last two years to customers.
We're sitting in a room
now where we're starting
to assemble our first production line.
And right now we're
targeting first deliveries
towards the end of this year.
But we're focused on consumer
electronics to start.
With the technology it's
definitely applicable
to larger battery applications
like EVs potentially grid storage.
And so that's on our roadmap.
Elsewhere in Silicon
Valley, another company
is working on an even more
ambitious battery design.
We started with the mission
of trying to narrow the gap that we
in combustion engine
based vehicles and EVs.
And we recognized that the key there
was to build a better battery.
We could usher in a new
era of transportation.
15 minute charge times,
better life performance
and even lower costs.
It turns out all those
problems can be addressed
if you just switch from a
carbon or carbon silicon anode
not to a lithium metal anode.
Usually the lithium in
lithium-ion batteries only refers
to the molecule was shuttling
between the cathode and anode.
Making the anode itself out of lithium
could double the energy
density of the battery.
A much bigger leap than
a silicon anode battery,
like in Enovix's.
We didn't invent the idea
of a lithium metal battery.
That idea has been around
for a very long time
even before lithium-ion
lithium metal batteries.
There's just one small problem.
Unfortunately, they're not safe.
So typically inside a battery,
the electrolyte is liquid
but an liquid electrolyte
for a lithium metal battery
causes the lithium metal to degrade
and sometimes even short and catch fire.
QuantumScape's main goal
was to try and replace
what is a liquid electrolyte
inside the battery
with a solid electrolyte.
The problem is that no one
has been able to make one
that conducts well enough
to compete with the liquid.
It wasn't clear that even the
material existed in nature
that could meet these requirements.
So we had to explore a
wide range of materials,
but luckily nature had a material
that meets the requirements
and our team was able to find it.
It's literally a solid material,
it's a ceramic material,
but it's kind of a very special material
because lithium-ions can
just zip right through it
like they're on a highway.
This single powered
cell is all QuantumScape
was able to show us of
they're solid state battery.
Ultimately they'll stack
100 of these together
to make a complete battery pack.
The company is still a few years
from selling a commercial product,
but the performance
improvements they're predicting
would be revolutionary.
We've shown that we can charge faster.
We can get 80% charge at 15 minutes,
which is gonna be really important
if you're on the road trip
or if you don't have a
garage to plug your car in
and charge overnight.
You can get longer range
by improving the energy
density of the battery.
What we've said is we're aiming
to have cars driving
with these cells in 2024.
So the next few years will be
about increasing the scale of production.
We formed a partnership
with Volkswagen in 2012
and they've announced that
they would partner with us
and make a joint venture
to commercialize the cells
and go into manufacturing together.
We think that with these batteries,
you're gonna be able to get EVs
that compete more effectively
with combustion engine-based vehicles.
You get more energy density,
you have lower costs and longer life.
So our mission right now
is to get these batteries on the road,
try to really transform
the automotive sector
and in the process really
make a dent on CO2 emissions.
Companies like QuantumScape and Enovix
are imagining a future in
which clean, affordable EVs
dominate the roads.
But the implications go
much further than that.
Better batteries are key
to almost every technology
that could slow down climate change.
Batteries are what are known
as an enabling technology
which is that you can use
a battery to make an impact
across different sectors of the economy
and across different
types of technologies.
So currently our batteries
can go in electric cars
but there's still a battery
that needs to go in a truck.
Then there needs to be a
battery that goes in a ship
and then there needs to be a battery
that can go in a plane.
There are now bigger and bigger batteries
being put on the grid
that help us increase
the amount of renewables
And all those things get a boost
with every little innovation
that happens in batteries.
And so the impact that
batteries can have is immense.